As a woman who spent 10 years as a tribe wife,
and I birthed four children unmedicated,
and I cloth diaper them, and I homeschooled,
and I baked our bread, and I made our meals from scratch,
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
That Ballerina Farms article was so triggering,
because you can hear the sadness in her voice.
You can.
What's funny is to sometimes,
like, hearing about other people's story,
it helps validate yours. Like,
I remember I would get this, like,
mystery illness, and that's what we called it.
We called it, oh,
Mommy's got her mystery illness.
Where it wasn't necessarily the flu.
We didn't know what it was.
I just got, like,
really sick, and I'd have, like,
a fever on and off and chills
and just, like,
like, literally couldn't get up and do anything for,
like, a week or two.
And funny enough, once I got a divorce and became a single mom,
I never got this mystery illness anymore.
I, I was just thinking about that, like, wow,
that doesn't happen anymore. Like,
there are so many things to touch on in that article,
and I'm a little bit obsessed about it,
and I'm gonna talk about each and every issue.
Because I lived her exact life.
Maybe I didn't have the same farm,
but I did have the same isolation.
Maybe I didn't have eight kids,
but I had four. Maybe I wasn't in a pageant after one of them,
but I Did have one.
Have open heart surgery a week before I gave birth to the next one.
Like, I've been in really similar situations,
you know,
I think a lot of women can relate to her story and what she's doing.
And you can kind of see how we try to be the little
perfect trophy for the one guy that's there
that we thought was gonna provide us a beautiful,
amazing life. But then when it comes time to it,
you get a fucking egg apron.
You don't even get what he fucking promised you you were gonna get.
Like,
the fact that this woman has eight children at her age.
Oh, my god.
Some women are on their eighth fucking vacation
that they paid for themselves and shit.
Like,
we have so much more to offer the world
than our fucking reproductive system,
and that's so hard on your body.
Oh, my god.
I don't even know where to begin,
but I'm literally obsessed with this.
I'm not. Oh, my god.